we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p we
interviewed earlier this week Marcelo
gleiser and during that he mentioned a
physicist werner heisenberg and i admit
as a big breaking bad fan when that
happened my mind for a second went to
bryan cranston portrayal of breaking bad
the egg man called in and apparently he
had the exact same thought Dave he said
Heisenberg twice I bet you smiled I did
right yes did you make that connection I
absolutely did because when i hear
heisenberg i think of breaking bad yes
although Heisenberg's very very I think
it is it I don't remember if Breaking
Bad has a reference to why he why Walter
White chooses the code name or the alibi
of Heisenberg but presumably it's
related to Werner Heisenberg right yeah
I'm absolutely I think that's why the
producers chose that name yeah okay but
well yes the Eggman and I clearly on the
same page as far as that goes on the
bonus show today a Russian official
wants to ban Beauty and the Beast over a
gay character have you heard of
something so stupid also since the
election of Donald Trump a formerly
quiet upstate New York Road has become a
very busy exit from the United States
we'll also talk to you about yelps new
feature which is meant to help track
businesses that have gender neutral
bathrooms okay very very interesting
stories on the bonus show sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership to get
access the coupon code i voted 17 still
available for your use